When no one listens to you,
we feel that once they see to all sorts
of things start to happen,
for instance,
you have so much pain inside yourself
that you try and hurt yourself on the
outside because you want help,
but it's the wrong help you're asking
for.
People see it as crying wolf or
attention seeking and they think because
you're in the media all the time,
you've got enough attention,
inverted commerce.
But I was actually crying out.
I wanted to get better in order to go
forward and continue my duty and my role
as a wife,
mother,
Princess of Wales.
So I,
uh,
yes,
I did influx for myself.
I didn't like myself.
I was ashamed because I couldn't cope
with the pressures.
What did you actually do?
Well,
I just taught my arms my next and I work
in environments now where I see women
doing similar things and I'm able to
understand completely where they're
coming from.
I think every strong woman in history
has had to walk down a similar path and
I think it's the strength that causes
the confusion,
the fear.
Why is she strong?
Where does she get it from?
Where she lives?
She going to use it.
I'd like to be a queen of people's
hearts and people's hearts and I don't
see myself being queen,
just country.
I don't think many people would want me
to be queen.
Actually,
when I say many people,
I mean established time,
married into because they've decided to
Salta.
Why do you think they've decided?
Because I do things differently because
I didn't go by when we book because
neutral,
the whole not the head and that's got me
into trouble in my work.
I understand that and show it.